hermann cortes was thrilled at the idea
of receiving the second dose of the
sinovac vaccine
but just hours before his appointment he
instead received a message
saying his shot was postponed until
further notice
i was so disappointed when i saw the
message i was looking forward to the
second shot
to finally be done with this and be free
to see my nephews
i don't understand why they didn't plan
to keep enough shots for those who got
the first one
and the 79 year old is not alone health
services in colombia have suspended
appointments for
thousands of people because they don't
have enough doses
so far just 2.7 percent of colombians
have been fully vaccinated
while six percent have received one dose
a recent report found that at this rate
it will take almost two years for the
vaccination campaign to make an
impact
to try to speed up the process the
government authorized large private
enterprises to buy vaccines
internationally for their employees
but manufacturers like pfizer and
sinovac say they will not
sell to private businesses for the time
being
both the government and the private
sector are recognizing
how the government's falling short of
its commitment to
vaccinate the entire colombian
population
it's more like a phyric victory by the
private sector
that they're now you know keeping praise
at the government for allowing them to
proceed
but there's really nothing that they can
do in the short term
to expand access to vaccination
all this happening while colombia is
enduring its worst crisis since the
start of the pandemic
averaging more than 400 deaths per day
and with intensive care units close to
collapse
colombia's capital bogota is under
strict weakened
lockdowns and has nightly curfews among
other restrictions and authorities are
expected to impose
more over the weekend the city set up
new field hospitals to try to ease the
pressure on the capital's held
infrastructure
while the mayor pleaded with people to
stay home
i know it's a major sacrifice and an
economic and emotional sacrifice
but please be certain it will not be in
vain
an authorities fear the next two weeks
could be particularly severe
as colombia's struggles with another
expected surge
alessandra al jazeera bogota